[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm on to you buddy
[Music]
mm-hmm
need some
you're about a lot of debt dealers the
ones that are finally talking saying doc
gasps stones in the system beneath the
big mouth jazz club you're not gonna try
to convince me to let you arrest him are
you if I wanted to arrest him I wouldn't
have let you be a part of this justice
might be blind but it shouldn't be
stupid to go do whatever it is you're
gonna do sure thing detective
[Applause]
how're you doing man
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mixing races it ain't natural what
thank y'all all
report back to the little s Raymond
[ __ ] up ballsy [ __ ] this weather
lately hope you enjoying your day
pardon me
[Music]
[Music]
to Patrol
my pops a big cheese drinking and
committed misogyny [ __ ] gone maybe I
should look over there just back me up -
yeah let's go
[Music]
[Music]
you have me pinned down this is nobody's
father Jose
[Music]
[Music]
see that [ __ ] okay he's all mad good
night
get me to a goddamn Hospital [ __ ]
freak
[Music]
[Music]